Special Counsel Robert Muller claims
former Trump campaign Chairman Paul
Manafort is trying to sway potential
witnesses in his fraud and money
laundering case prosecutors want a judge
to decide if Manta fort should go to
jail until his upcoming trial Paula Reid
is at the White House Paula good morning
good morning Paul Manafort has so far
refused to cooperate in the Special
Counsel investigation in the hope that
he would receive a presidential pardon
if he is convicted but it appears he may
not be so confident about that
possibility of a pardon as he is now
accused of trying to tamper with
witnesses ahead of his upcoming trial he
has done nothing wrong and this is a
horrible not only a horrible perversion
of justice this has got to come to an
end while President Trump's personal
attorney Rudy Giuliani was calling for
an end to the Russia investigation
robert muller accused trump's former
campaign chairman Paul Manafort of
trying to coach witnesses who may be
called to testify against him mana Ford
allegedly used encrypted messaging apps
and an intermediary to contact two
former business associates sources tell
CBS News that mana Ford is banking on a
presidential pardon if he is convicted
but there's no evidence he's been
promised one the president hasn't done
anything wrong and wouldn't have any
need for a pardon
White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders addressed the possibility of the
president pardoning himself repeatedly
saying the president had done nothing
wrong but told reporters certainly no
one is above the law
but the president tweeted earlier Monday
that he had the absolute right to
pardoned myself but why would I do that
when I have done nothing wrong Monday
night Giuliani again argued the
president could pardon himself if he
wished the pardon power is complete and
there is no limitation on it the
president's Republican Capitol Hill
allies said that would be a grave
mistake
politically it'd be a terrible idea
actually imagine a president even
that comes from Giuliani also defended
Sarah Sanders and the president's other
attorneys over statements they made
alleging the president had no role in
crafting a misleading statement about
his son's 2016 Trump Tower meeting with
a group of Russians we now know the
president actually dictated that
statement but Giuliani said Sanders and
the other attorneys they weren't lying
they were merely mistaken John all right
Paula we're also in other news one week
away from the summit with North Korea
who is working most closely with the
President on the negotiations well
traditionally that would fall to the
National Security Adviser in this case
John Bolton but CBS News has learned
that there is tension between the
president and John Bolton the president
was especially upset about comments that
Bolton made on Face the Nation
comparing the North Korean negotiations
to the denuclearization of Libya which
obviously upset a lot of North Koreans
so the president has given his Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo the lead ahead of
the summit fascinating Paula thank you